hey youtubers is Charlie you guys asked
for a dark side video so here we go
couple of the actors actually confirmed
something about the opening scene of the
movie so I'm going to explain what's
going on the actor who plays Roose
Bolton on Game of Thrones confirmed the
opening scene of the movie is this big
battle here so I'm going to play this
clip for context just like a portion of
the trailer and then I'll explain how
dark sides the other villains fit into
the movie because there's a lot of big
concepts when you talk about dark side
villains
[Music]
shall we bunch of really cool darkside
specific things confirmed about Justice
League so one ciarán hinds is going to
be playing Steppenwolf he talked about
what the look of his character is going
to be and how he fits into the movie the
original Age of Heroes that was never
supposed to come again that Wonder Woman
was talking about in the trailer so if
you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get everything I do DC
videos every week but because there's
still a few things that we don't know
about Darkseid's forces his minions
specifically and I wanted to do a video
about them I'll start with the stuff
that we know about this scene here and
the way they fit into the movie then
I'll talk about them in the comics
because even if they cut a bunch of
characters out of the movie there's
usually still a lot of Easter eggs for
the biggest comic book things in
Darkseid is the biggest comic book thing
that DC has ever tried to do but let's
start with this big scene here this
might wind up being the prequel the Jack
Snyder does before a lot of his movies
like they had the Batman prequel before
Batman V Superman that sort of told his
origin story it's almost like a really
cool silent film I don't think they
could do something this epic is a silent
film but this is supposedly earth
because you see Amazon's charging into
battle here you see some Atlanteans
teaming up with them so they're not
super clear on the timeline this could
be hundreds of years ago thousands of
years ago the forces of Earth came
together in the Age of Heroes to fight
off the forces of apocalypse you see
them fighting thousands and thousands of
parademons you see Darkseid's troop
ships in the background in this giant
beam coming down from the sky that's
probably what's creating all these fire
lines that are running across the ground
and you see a lot of shots that look
like this type of terrain mirrored in
present day with like Aquaman's
character taking down parademons so one
that could be another terraforming
device the way the Kryptonians were
trying to terraform during the Man of
Steel movie or Darkseid's trying to
physically get something that's buried
beneath the earth or even three is
trying to release something we do not
have confirmation of actual Darkseid
physically being in this scene because
even though they tease Panos at the end
of the first Avengers movie the DC
movies try to differentiate themselves a
little bit so it sounds like Darkseid is
going to be this more ethereal threat
behind this physical threat here that
will later make himself known during
whatever that second Justice League
movie is going to be it's all still
speculation at this point but I do not
think the actor who plays Roose Bolton
is talking about himself playing
darkside when he talks about his scene
that he has during this moment so I'll
play the audio clip up in here sound
insane I did which is quite a well at
the moment I continue to be kind of
opening scene was was pretty dark
actually in its tone but in a good way
you know not in a I thought in a and I
quite liked that it wasn't comic-book II
but I think you know you can thread a
certain amount of humor through it which
maybe the previous one was lacking his
passion for it for the for those
characters I mean he just lives those
those comic books you know he absolutely
adores them and he's an aficionado which
I'm not at all actually
and he does have his stylish slow-mo
style and he knows exactly what he wants
and yet he's amazingly loose and open to
suggestions from actors and lines thrown
in for something that is such a giant
machine that you would have thought that
was you know locked off with exacts but
there was an enormous meta freedom with
that I thought was pretty good he really
doesn't give much away he has that deep
booming voice he could be playing in
Atlantian he could be playing one of
Darkseid's elite I don't think they're
going to do all of darkseid the lead in
the movie but it sounds like his
characters and their very briefly and
will not reappear later in the movie so
what it sounds like they're doing is as
they're showing you like the epic scope
of dark sides power in this big battle
here like this is what's going to happen
if the Justice League doesn't come
together then later in the movie
Steppenwolf the actual villain of
Justice League played by Ciaran Hinds
comes in with the force of parademons to
try and recover the mother boxes so that
he can bring Darkseid back so you get
the full Darkseid enchilada it'd be like
slipping to the last page of a comic
book for the big reveal and then they
leave them out like you would
traditionally do in a big movie like you
base this big going you put a team
together he slinks away by sequel
villain movie rules he builds his own
evil team which has dark sides elite
comes back to kick your ass big time so
this is like a standard movie
progression so even if they reference a
lot of dark sides other elite characters
during this opening scene I'm only
expecting to see Steppenwolf during the
climax of the move
with a bunch of parademons and he's
powerful enough to take on the entire
Justice League by himself like that's
how bad he is so you have to imagine how
much worse it would be if all of
Darkseid's elite we're working together
so this big opening scene doesn't really
do it justice this is a really up close
shot of what the parademons would look
like and they might polish the cg on
this just a little bit but if there was
any confusion about why Steppenwolf is
coming to the earth during Justice
League it's because Darkseid wants the
mother boxes there are three of them one
of them is now become cyborg so that's a
big problem like oh my god what's going
to happen to cyborg if the mother box
has become him does that mean that
Darkseid is going to have to dismantle
him now we're going to move slowly into
comic book stuff so some of this is a
little speculation but they typically
don't change too many things usually the
big ideas stick is that mother boxes
draw their power from the source if
you've never heard of this source
it's an idea from the Jack Kirby fourth
world comics where all life all
superheroes in the universe draw their
power from it's like this mythical
energy field that gives people that draw
in an infinite power so this source of
crazy power so of course
Darkseid would want that it's almost
like the way people in the Avengers
movies try to wield the power of the
infinity gems a source of infinite power
they usually becomes as big MacGuffin
for the hero's journey so that's what
the mother boxes are in respect to
Justice League this source of infinite
power but they also have a bunch of
other crazy powers too they allow
instantaneous travel between two points
in the universe so Darkseid could like
portal all of his forces to earth from
apocalypse if he wanted to if he had
control of them other boxes but they go
way beyond that they're just a source of
infinite power so like that's the big
takeaway they tend to have really simple
ideas that look really fantastical on
screen so that's what this battle is
over here they're trying to fight off
Darkseid and they explain in the history
of the world because this is happening
before the Wonder Woman movie picks up
like Wonder Woman isn't fighting in this
big crowd here but they did confirm that
the Wonder Woman movie would tell the
history of the DC EU because the Amazons
are so long-lived just like the
Atlanteans if you're not familiar with
Wonder Woman's origin story there's a
couple different versions of it she's
the daughter of Zhu
in Hippolyta so she might be a child
while this is happening in Zeus has died
all the crazy stuff that Ares instigated
to kill the other gods that's happened a
long time ago by the time that she's
been born so the forces of Earth come
together fight off Darkseid and it
leaves them with three mother boxes on
the planet we know the Atlanteans
possess one of them the Amazons got
another one in the third one we don't
know where it went we just see it get
sucked up into cyborg as it integrates
with him and he becomes the cyborg
character so let me know what you guys
think about the way they're using this
like really quick money shot to explain
the history of the DC EU in conjunction
with the Wonder Woman movie so if you
were on the fence that's why it's really
important to go see the Wonder Woman
movie in June before you go see Justice
League in November but the other
Darkseid elite that they could
potentially bring into the movie there
are a lot of them but they're just a
couple really big main ones you can read
just John's Darkseid war where they
introduced most of them in the idea of
the Furies so there's dark sides elite
then there's the Furies two different
forces the Furies as you can imagine is
a female team that's led by granny
goodness it is a big badass group of
female characters led by big Barda who's
kind of a more evil ambiguous version of
Wonder Woman that's kind of what her
power levels like but there's granny
goodness is younger sister Amazing Grace
there's desaad glorious Godfrey Kalibak
whose dark sides eldest son he's the big
guy he would definitely be CG there's
Kanto who's more of an assassin
Steppenwolf himself whose dark sides
uncle his chief lieutenant and he's
actually going to be a big CG character
so it's going to be ciarán hinds face
with a giant CG body so that'll explain
how he's able to take on the Justice
League because when you look at him
standing around he doesn't look that
powerful so if this person were to fight
the Justice League it wouldn't look that
spectacular so it's going to look really
crazy they haven't revealed what his
actual look is like but you get a brief
peek at it when Lex Luthor is communing
with the Kryptonian ship those are just
a few of Darkseid's biggest elite now
there's always more minor characters so
we could see any number of them in the
Justice League movies but I'm not
expecting to see a lot of them at least
until we get to the second
Justice League movie in a lot of what
happens during that is still on the
fence a lot of it just depends on what
happens with these next couple of movies
they tend to adjust their plans just
based on financial success like we have
all these Batman movie coming out we
have Nightwing we have the Batgirl movie
coming they didn't plan those when they
first started making the Justice League
movie that just came about recently and
there's a lot of talk about what's going
on with the Black Adam character in the
DC EU how he might be more of a Superman
villain that's all still up in the air
so it's still open to wide speculation I
know you're all wondering when we're
going to see more Justice League footage
I'm not expecting to get another trailer
til the Wonder Woman movie comes out so
it's not that far off believe all your
requests for DC videos in the comments
below I know everybody's freaking out
about the flash because that's coming
back next week there's all these
character deaths that we're wondering
about so if there's new footage I will
totally do a video for it but there's
plenty more DC coming later this week
while you wait for that you can click
here to re-watch the Justice League
trailer and you can click here to learn
all about what's going on with the flash
thank you so much for watching let's
high-five I'll see you guys in the next
video
you